hey i'm new here but we're basically the  most popular and prestigious streaming  service right that's right because we  cater to the viewers and care about good  storytelling exactly well let's stop  that what what can you just delete an  entire movie for me again uh why also  let's make sure animation is not a thing  animation is dumb it's for babies also  have you heard of discovery plus i don't  think anyone has let's merge with them  because uh  i don't know they have shark week what  also let's make everything less diverse  because i saw this bumper sticker on the  back of a 2007 jeep wrangler and thought  this must be universally true